so I'm going to start with I like
throwing a curve first of all congrats
on the movie this is going to be a big
hit but I like throwing a curve at the
beginning if someone is actually never
seen anything you've done before and it
could be this movie what is the thing
that you would like them to watch first
and why
I mean I have a lot but like they're all
in Indonesia so
um
um
Maybe
maybe I'll I'll be book smart for you oh
I'm sick I actually does a lot
I just love book smart it was a part of
my life for a long time and then it's so
dope sick if you want to kind of get a
little bit like yeah or Unstoppable word
when you want to go to like into heavy
yeah uh-huh yeah it's a little smart and
what about you me
um I don't know
I I quite like this movie like uh that I
didn't run I think 2013 or something I
was kind of I was a young boy
uh it was called meet me after sunset uh
yeah I did like a whole like soundtrack
on it I sang in the movie it was pretty
fun yeah well that's cool it represents
yeah both worlds that I yeah
that's the most exciting I can't imagine
making a movie with George and Julia
please I can't imagine but for each of
you who was the most excited of your
friends and family when you told them
I'm making a movie and it's with George
and Julia I mean gosh I guess I guess me
I was I mean my family was like they
they're super chill about the the two of
them I think I get that question a lot
which is like what did your parents
think of them being your parents but
they're really like chill super like
down to earth people
um I mean I guess I guess
my my sisters thought it was pretty cool
yeah yeah I mean I was more like nervous
but like my friends were excited for
music oh my God you guys oh Maxim Maxim
yeah yeah my best friend was actually
really excited yeah they'll be the first
one you call you know like even like
during the audition process yeah that's
true guys yeah I knew there was someone
yeah you know but I would imagine for
both of you um no matter how every time
you make something you must learn from
the experience and George and Julia have
both been doing this for a very long
time what did you pick up watching them
on set that you said to yourself I need
to bring with this with me to everything
I do in the future
[Music]
um
I think the two of them really made sure
that everybody was having a good time
and having fun and that was a big
priority I think for the both of them
um and I think when you are again
everybody is nervous to to meet them
because of their their background and
their careers they've both had and
that's that's a scary nerve-wracking
feeling to be in their presence but they
never ever made anybody feel nervous or
they always welcomed everybody in so I
think just constantly remind I guess
moving forward in my career I think just
remembering that part of it that like
having a good time on set is is the most
important thing and that's always what I
try to do on all of my jobs is to work
with good and nice people
um because then why are why are we doing
this yes
um and then I did notice that Julia
meditates
um a lot on set or would I would I would
I do know that about her and I think
that that's a really
important yeah
or like naps like yeah just kind of like
taking a moment to to rest because it
can be sort of like because sometimes
you just want to make it chaotic and
yeah on so yeah that's a nice thing I'm
gonna maybe consider moving forward on
my jobs
meditate yoga yep do some yoga on on set
sorry guys I need to do yoga that's
right no but it's true though your
mental well-being absolutely 100 I'm
glad more people talk about it it's so
it's very important yeah yeah I agree
yeah you know um is there a day or two
well actually I want to switch I love
obviously like everybody else the beer
pong scene is my last thing the beer
pong thing beer pong scene and the
dancing talk a little bit about filming
that sequence because it's fantastic
yeah I mean it was fantastic if I was
watching like we didn't know what was
gonna happen all I know is that I
remember all said like okay so they're
going to be here sometimes they're going
to be there but we don't really know
what's going to happen yeah all right
yeah they it was supposed to it was a
scene that was supposed to that
paragraphed I think
I think said no to choreography and they
just really just were winging it in that
scene so what you're seeing in the movie
is full just uh just out of nowhere just
going for it and we were just in awe it
was incredible and George is really good
at beer pong and they're making the he
did not miss a shot yeah really really
didn't I'm never gonna play with him on
that note I need to go congratulations
on the movie good luck with your speed
dating thank you
thank you